I'm just jets nixed now because the
Rangers in Yanks won that's right I'm an
actual winner life god I know but I'm
the best I looked you directly in the
face Tim it wasn't even like so bitter
I'm such a happy human but when I come
into console it or being here looking at
all the happiness from all these
Patriots you got your prospective happy
don't you want to be happy
[Music]
you see it in real life yeah that's it
this is the flag in the ground every
single piece of video content I put out
ever again has that tag up front a
period so that's that you know what's
cool about it is it's gonna be an
awesome sticker everyone's gonna do it
yeah I'm gonna own it I'm gonna write
the article right now smart titled who
came up with it the clip the audio thing
concept of you were doing it
me yeah yeah why do you think I well I
think it's getting done why do think
it's happening you know it's a great
idea but I honestly believe that that's
how everybody works and that's you know
like that's right there was I just don't
think most there was one time and I was
like bro like bro I literally walked you
through this two weeks ago
[Music]
[Applause]
but there is a place where everybody
like is disliked what I the reason I've
been successful in business is I'm not
emotional in business that's why people
lose a business they make emotional
decisions I make no emotional decisions
that's good can I rate them because I
don't even know I like I might own so I
don't think I have any good that's like
a be love hey hey hey
I [ __ ] Erika's a [ __ ] G in general
but net net is a super a turn again are
you confused when somebody says net net
it means the bottom [ __ ] line [ __ ]
well cuz that means it - do you live on
buzzwords the foundation of this whole
[ __ ] organization is much worse
[Music]
deep dives are you guys making some
stuff happened down there I think you
know this I'm not optimistic
you can go search eight jet traffic's on
YouTube where my brother and I are doing
the [ __ ] result like I'm not
optimistic I've cried on the
announcement of a new head coach but in
this scenario I am
I think Adam GaSe is going to dominate
yeah I do I really do I totally believe
it I'm not you know what the best part
about this is here's the best part the
amount of times I'm gonna clip you doing
that when we win a Super Bowl in your
[ __ ] mouth is gonna be remarkable
guess what I got good I got good news
I'm not this [ __ ] dude I love you I'm
just saying I'm not your listen I love
you I know what boat we're in I know
exactly the boat we're on let me set up
straight to the camera yep yep what's up
guys I'm Gary Vaynerchuk and I'm ready
to answer the internet Oh should I got
to read would you rather have everyone
naked at all times or everyone clothes
naked at all times yeah everybody your
grandmother oh don't judge people bro
would you rather sit down with your
parents and watch every sexual encounter
you've had or watch your parents sex
tape when they've conceived you sex tape
where they conceived me cuz it's the
greatest moment that ever happened yes I
picked I filmed it yesterday I filmed it
the video comes out tomorrow that's
[ __ ] crazy time you did that's
awesome guys thank you so much have a
great week enjoy Thanks Casey thanks
around my back see ya see ya say guys
for me it's the at-bat I
that we are stunningly lacking the
gratitude of actually being a human
being in the first place there's nothing
you'll ever accomplish that it's
remotely more remarkable that then that
you actually were a human being the math
is so absurd I'm so driven by [ __ ]
gratitude I can't believe I have a life
you could have been a [ __ ] tree
pink that seriously good it was a tree
it looks like I just wish people
understood one of the one of the things
I tell people all the time is you know
right now we're living through an
amazing era of putting youth on a
pedestal because of Technology right
these last 10 15 years is like the 20
year old is on right like like when I'm
43 when you were 20 and you went into a
business you did dumb [ __ ] for 10 years
like in turn and like get the coffee now
kids come into businesses and like to
put on a pedestal because they
understand technology so right now in
our society the last
we put youth on a pedestal I'm
completely convinced that the counter to
this and what I'm watching is that we're
gonna put wisdom and age and experience
on a pedestal next so I think for all
the seventy five to ninety nine year
olds out there your ear is next and I'm
being serious about that I would tell
you the amount of people here that would
massively benefit from going and
volunteering for five hours at a
retirement home and having two
meaningful conversations with somebody
eighty or older that is not somebody
you're related to and if you understood
and listen and watch their energy you
would understand how lucky we are to
have our years ahead of us how much you
don't want to live life based on trying
to you need to be in a place where you
don't regret the things you didn't do
you know and I just I just think we lack
perspective and I think we talked a lot
about privilege of like right now thank
God race and gender and we're having
that conversation we're not having that
conversation around ageism right like we
don't have to wait we're finally
starting to have some decent level of a
conversation of trying to have empathy
for different backgrounds races things
that make sure but I'm telling you the
biggest lack of perspective in this room
everybody in this room is people are
anxious and insecure because they
haven't accomplished something and they
haven't even gone out of the fund the
first quarter so I highly recommend you
realize that you've got us buffaloed of
yours in front of you and slow at the
[ __ ] down what did you just say that
can't be real that can't be real my
heart just broke
that's that better not be real that
can't be real hold on why that can't be
real
hey Jay what the [ __ ] baby how are you
but looking forward to meeting you guys
looking forward to meeting so long time
I actually went look
for you one time a friend of mine sent
me some stuff I was like man this guy
stinks just like I do and then I saw the
video where you were pulling out the
action figures yeah I love to show my
daughter this one this week this mine
[ __ ] traded porzingis I'm so [ __ ]
pissed [ __ ] [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate this
franchise this better [ __ ] mean that
Anthony Davis is coming here and that's
the back end of this today thank you
what's going I appreciate that I just
don't understand that [ __ ] trade at
all inside you guys thank you I'll see
you I'll see you tomorrow night
this is catastrophic like just an
explosive [ __ ] ridiculously stupid
deal [ __ ] dead dead I'm dead I'm dead
like we finally have a [ __ ] moment
there's something somewhat interesting
because we try to keep KP and I'm dead
there's all sorts of good content that
team rocks got the camera down how many
times you want me to say [ __ ]
arbitrage like Jesus Christ we finally
have something KP is gonna be the
top-five player in the NBA I just want
it right in our mouths
how the [ __ ] are the two best players
I'm drafted my team's drafted the last
20 [ __ ] years of Revis and KP what
happened is you got emotional people
making emotional decisions now the
contents gone do you rock you missed the
moment it's so common no it is vlog I
put out all sorts of red stuff that
you've never seen cuz D rocks always
weirdly like had the camera down when we
had finally something interesting like
real like a real unique moment that we
could have looked back on 35 years the
most disastrous moment in exports
history and yet you did it and really
what the big question is is what are you
doing your time focus emotions and
excitement you have played I guess if
you added this in my camp is magic
[ __ ] in [ __ ] Atlanta with a bunch
of [ __ ] Patriot fans making fun of
the mix [ __ ]
what's that no but it wasn't a great
video yeah it couldn't couldn't and it
wasn't fault I was ok with that because
I knew that it couldn't get like the you
had a really actually do a mix of the
funniness of that call it's a much
better yeah
could have done a carousel and it
probably would have done well got it and
did do well know that it you know what
else doesn't look good this [ __ ]
train
[Music]